[Música]
tragedia en el canal de la mancha -27
personas perdieron la vida en la obra
gar la embarcación en la que intentaban
llegar a las costas del reino unido
desde francia en este país cuatro
personas acusadas de tráfico de personas
fueron arrestadas
honduras irá a las urnas este domingo
para unas cruciales elecciones generales
en donde además de elegir al nuevo
presidente y alcaldes elegirán a los
integrantes del congreso nacional un
legislativo que podría instaurar una
misión anti corrupción con respaldo
internacional analizamos este tema en
minutos aquí en france 24
colombia conmemora cinco años de la
firma del acuerdo de paz entre el
gobierno y la extinta guerrilla de las
farc un acuerdo con luces y sombras en
torno a la implementación a las
garantías que aún hoy siguen generando
debates en la sociedad colombiana
tenemos los detalles en minutos
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález estamos en vivo desde nuestros
estudios en bogotá en colombia ya son 27
los muertos que dejó el naufragio de una
embarcación en aguas del canal de la
mancha una embarcación que transportaba
decenas de emigrantes que intentaban
llegar al reino unido desde las costas
del norte de francia precisamente el
presidente francés emmanuel marco no
pidió a la unión europea hacer un
esfuerzo conjunto de las autoridades
fronterizas por su parte el reino unido-
hizo un llamado para luchar contra el
tráfico de personas en la zona del canal
de la mancha
andrés amaya tiene los detalles en el
siguiente informe
a dónde vas ahora
a reino unido
el peligroso recorrido para atravesar el
canal de la mancha ha provocado la
muerte de decenas de emigrantes con
temperaturas bajo cero muchos viajan por
uno de los corredores más transitados
del mundo hacia el reino unido pero no
todos logran cumplir sus sueños de una
vida mejor algunos mueren ahogados o
congelados francia urgió a acelerar el
desmantelamiento de las redes criminales
que están detrás de esto que le ponía
responsable excepto nombres y cohesión
sólo para ser la mayor responsabilidad
de esta despreciable situación está en
los contrabandistas es decir los
delincuentes que por miles de euros
organizan la trata de personas desde
edad afganistán áfrica así luego hacen
venir a esas personas y para bélgica
países bajos y francia para cruzar el
canal de la mancha e ir a reino unido
son estos contrabandistas los que
tenemos que combatir el amor
por su parte el primer ministro
británico instó a los socios europeos de
reino unido a cerrar aún más las
fronteras y su empuje hui
axa grave y posible es importante que
aceleremos todas las medidas contenidas
en nuestros proyectos de ley de
fronteras y nacionalidades para que
podamos distinguir entre las personas
que vienen aquí legalmente y las
personas que vienen ilegalmente también
hacemos todo lo que podemos y no dejamos
piedra sin remover para demoler la
propuesta comercial de los traficantes
de personas y las mafias el régimen
traficantes de inmigrantes el número de
emigrantes que viaja en pequeñas
embarcaciones para cruzar el canal de la
mancha ha crecido drásticamente este año
más de 25 mil 700 personas han realizado
el peligroso viaje las autoridades
francesas y británicas han recogido a
miles de personas en ambas costas en las
últimas semanas en decenas de
operaciones de rescate
y en eeuu un tribunal del estado de
georgia condenó a tres hombres por el
asesinato del ciudadano afroamericano
ahmed yabri en febrero del 2020 para
muchos el caso de harvey es muestra de
la injusticia social en los eeuu los
hombres le dispararon tras haberse
asegurado que era sospechoso de cometer
un crimen manuel acá no nos amplia más
en su informe
gritos abrazos y lágrimas de alegría así
recibió una multitud a las afueras de un
tribunal de georgia la noticia de que
tres hombres blancos fueron condenados
por asesinar a good are very en febrero
de 2020 dentro del recinto el juez
anunció que gray cmac mike con su hijo
travis mcmichael y su vecino william
brady bryant fueron hallados culpables
de asesinar a abril mientras corría por
el vecindario los acusados lo atacaron
después de que uno de ellos denunciara
que un hombre afroamericano que portaba
un arma se veía sospechoso
al principio nunca pensé que este día
llegaría a decir verdad nunca había este
día en 2020 ahora que es al que conoces
como ahmed y yo lo conozco como que es
ahora va a descansar en paz
tras una deliberación que se prolongó
durante 10 horas el jurado determinó que
suavice mcmichael fue responsable de
nueve cargos incluido el de asesinato
malicioso del cual fueron declarados
inocentes 'break' mcmichael y brian una
decisión que llevó al presidente
estadounidense a hacer un reconocimiento
al sistema de justicia
nada puede traer al señor albert y de
regreso a su familia y a su comunidad
pero el veredicto asegura que aquellos
que cometieron este horrible crimen
serán castigados para muchos el caso de
harvard y es un ejemplo de la injusticia
racial en eeuu una acusación que tendrá
que pasar por un juicio federal en
febrero donde se determinará si el
asesinato de arví tuvo motivos raciales
vamos a cambiar de tema hablamos ahora
de honduras este país el próximo domingo
irá a las urnas para unas elecciones
generales en medio de un ambiente de
incertidumbre de pandemia de kobe 19
violencia política y también firmes
señalamientos hacia algunos de los
candidatos por estar implicados en casos
de corrupción y de crimen organizado el
ganador de los comicios sucederá al
cuestionado presidente juan orlando
hernández hermano de juan antonio
hernández condenado por la fiscalía del
distrito sur de nueva york en 2019 por
narcotráfico los hondureños también
elegirán alcaldes y elegirán a los
integrantes del congreso nacional un
legislativo que podría instaurar una
misión anti corrupción con respaldo
internacional para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a gustavo irías analista
político y director del centro de
estudios para la democracia en honduras
lo saludamos en la ciudad de tegucigalpa
la capital hondureña señorías gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en france 24
y estas elecciones en honduras giran en
torno a un cambio de dirección en el
país para salvar
la institucionalidad digámoslo así o por
el contrario dejar honduras a merced de
la corrupción y de la impunidad qué
posibilidades hay de enderezar el camino
de este país centroamericano como lo ve
usted
bueno muchas gracias buenas tardes
en realidad la esencia de la disputa
electoral
en honduras para este 28 de noviembre ya
tenemos pocos días
es realmente entre un régimen
autoritario y corrupto que se instaló en
el país desde el golpe de estado del
y una amplia coalición
y poco vista en estos últimos años en
américa latina desde una derecha
democrática por lo
cruzado acompañado por los diferentes
centros políticos y sectores de
izquierda que buscan
instalar recuperar la democracia y la
decencia nacional me parece que es ese
es el debate central es en la esencia la
disputa sí que en este momento está
planteada
señorías que tanta confianza hay en este
proceso en la transparencia que pueda
tener también en las autoridades
electorales de honduras que tan
independientes son y en la corrupción
que ya prácticamente ha abordado varias
instituciones
el gobierno allí en honduras
bueno esa es la gran pregunta
que tiene la mayoría de la ciudadanía
actores incluso internacionales que está
acompañando ampliamente este proceso
porque hay que recordar que venimos de
un fraude electoral
las elecciones pasadas fueron
fraudulentas e incluso reconocidas por
la misma visión de observación de la
organización de estados américanos que
en algún momento incluso llegó a
proponer la repetición de las elecciones
pero dado el reconocimiento por el
gobierno estadounidense el
resultado electoral la verdad dio muchos
pasos hacia atrás
y si el fuego el fantasmal
desgraciadamente hay una
institucionalidad electoral bastante
frágil marcada por muchos descensos
señor dirías también hay mucha
expectativa en torno a la elección de
los integrantes del congreso nacional
porque precisamente este nuevo
legislativo podría aprobar la
instauración de una misión anti
corrupción que podría contar con el
respaldo de otros países o de organismos
internacionales será posible usted cómo
ve esto
es posible es una de las esperanzas que
existe de hecho estas elecciones por eso
tienen un carácter histórico y
despiertan a pesar de la difícil
situación del país muchas esperanzas en
esta amplia coalición de fuerzas de
oposición
tener una mayoría
siempre una mayoría calificada el
congreso es clave para desmontar todo
este régimen autoritario y para poder
avanzar
en
reinstalar una visión internacional
contra la corrupción que ya la tuvimos
pero que fue expulsada a principios de
2020 sí señor gustavo irías muchas
gracias por este análisis desde la
ciudad de tegucigalpa en la capital de
honduras vamos a cambiar de tema
hablamos ahora de colombia se cumplen 5
años de la firma del acuerdo de paz
entre el gobierno colombiano y la
extinta guerrilla de las farc que puso
fin a 50 años de conflicto armado
autoridades colombianas y también
internacionales además de víctimas y ex
participaron del acto conmemorativo y si
bien destacaron los avances señalaron
las imperfecciones y el reto que tiene
el acuerdo de paz en este país para
alcanzar una paz duradera entre los
invitados destacados estuvo el
secretario general de la organización de
naciones unidas el portugués antonio
gutiérrez quien aprovechando su paso por
colombia ha visitado varias zonas que en
el pasado fueron blanco de la violencia
y se refirió a la implementación del
acuerdo y a la necesidad de prestar
atención a los asesinatos de los líderes
sociales y ambientales en las zonas
rurales escuche nacional
hago eco de sus llamadas que simplemente
el acuerdo de manera integral que se
protege a las comunidades vulnerables a
mujeres y hombres líderes sociales ex
combatientes de comunidades y de manera
muy especial los de los líderes
ambientales y reitero mi llamado para la
cooperación plena de todos con las
entidades del sistema de justicia
transicional en respecto por su
independencia y con el deseo de ver la
efectiva reparación y también las
sanciones necesarias en todo el proceso
de justicia seguimos hablando de este
tema el ex presidente colombiano juan
manuel santos tras la firma del acuerdo
de paz entre el estado y la guerrilla de
las farc o extinta guerrilla de las farc
prometió que en 2021 no quedarían minas
antipersonales en territorio colombiano
esto no ha sido cumplido y a diario se
registran víctimas sin embargo la paz
provocó el nacimiento de varias
organizaciones como por ejemplo
humanicemos dh que está formada por
integrantes por desminadores ex
combatientes de la guerrilla de la
y de integrantes del gobierno nuestros
periodistas lluis muñoz y aurora varios
presenciaron una de sus operaciones
veamos cuénteme don luís que para acá
que acabó encontrar un grupo de ex
combatientes de las extintas farc ha
encontrado un artefacto
pero podemos decir que que puede ser una
una mina antipersonal un campesino les
había avisado de que en su predio podría
haber explosivos de la guerra y no le
subimos junto a sus compañeros juan
carlos prepara una barricada que reduzca
el daño medioambiental
después mediante una barra de acero van
a disparar contra el artefacto muy lejos
listo vámonos
acá para que no para evitar riesgos los
desminadores se esconden para todas la
unidades y tiene la fuego en un minuto
un riesgo donde una persona puede se
puede un animal se puede accidental lo
estamos quitando pues por eso estos
disparos son mejores que los que
hacíamos antes
fuego en el área
y
decíamos que no se crea contenedor será
no no lo haya visto alguna vez pero
puede ser sí sí sí lo utilizaban como
contenedores de para ser para fabricar
minas humanicemos es el resultado de los
acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno y la
guerrilla de las farc de 2016 aunque su
operación no empezó hasta 2020 reciben
financiación del fondo europeo para la
paz y su actividad está monitoreada por
un más el servicio de acción contra las
minas de las naciones unidas tiene más
de 100 trabajadores y es la primera
organización de desminado del mundo
formada íntegramente por desminadores
firmantes de paz cada día se desplazan a
los remotos lugares que ocupaban cuando
eran combatientes de artefactos que
germán balanta es gerente de terreno en
las farc era comandante la
reincorporación trata de mantener las
estructuras anteriores con un fin muy
diferente fuimos un actor del conflicto
y que también colocamos minas y hoy la
estamos retirando
la vuelta a la vida civil ha significado
una nueva oportunidad
para la chica
cómo estás
[Música]
yo muy feliz en esta vida porque ya soy
una más con mi familia pero el impacto
del desminado también llega a las
comunidades en colombia cada día hay más
de una víctima por minas antipersonal
el área que se despejó el verdader ya
está volviendo a un resguardo de los
indígenas embera chamí apenas un mes
antes devolvieron el territorio libre de
minas podemos caminar en este es por
esta área es muy grato saber eso y es
parte de ustedes que también agradecidos
y nosotros es también un desminado que
permite que los niños hoy puedan volver
a pisar los caminos de un futuro que
sueñan que sea de paz
esto en las noticias buenas noches
[Música]